Well, what you're doing in order to make
that work and what you end up doing in
supervised learning and
functions approximation in general,
is you make some fundamental
assumptions about the work, right?
You decide that you have a well-behaved
function that is consistent with
the data that you're given, and with
that, you're able to generalize, and
in fact that is the fundamental
problem in machine learning.
It is generalization.
Now what's behind all of is
I'm going to claim, Michael,
you jump in whenever you disagree is
>> I disagree sorry to soon, go ahead.
>> is bias and in particular
>> bias
>> inductive bias.
>> Inductive bias.
>> Right, so all of machine learning or
certainly supervised learning is about
induction, as opposed to deduction.
>> I see.
Induction of course being a problem of
going from examples to
a more general rule.
>> Right, specifics to generalities.
By contrast, deduction is?
>> Be the opposite.
It would be going from a general
rule to specific instances,
basically like reasoning.
>> Right, and in fact,
a lot of AI in the beginning
was about deductive reasoning,
about logic programming, those sorts of
things, where you have certain rules,
and you deduce only those things that
follow immediately from those rules.
So for example,
you'd have something like A implies B.
That's a rule in the universe.
And then I tell you A.
So if you A implies B is a rule in
the universe, and I tell you A,
then you also know?
>> That A implies B.
>> And therefore you can infer that?
>> And A. B. >> B.
You have A implies B,
you have A, that implies B.
>> Okay.
>> That's what we just said.
But what,
>> that's deduction.
>> That's deduction, but
we just did was not deduction.
Before then when I asked you one, one,
two, four, three, nine, four sixteen and
so forth.
>> Right,
>> we did induction.
>> That was induction.
>> Induction is more about
did the sun rise yesterday?
>> yes.
>> Did the sun rise the day before that?
>> I slept in.
Did the sun rise the day before that?
>> Yes.
So the sun has risen every day.
Is the sun going to rise tomorrow?
>> I sure hope so.
>> We all hope so, and
we all act like it does,
because if it doesn't, then there are a
whole bunch of other things we ought to
be doing besides sitting in this
studio and having this interview.
>> I think we should warn the plants.
>> [LAUGH] I don't think
the plants are going to care.
>> They are.
They really need sun.
I think we all need sun, Mike.
>> Eh.
>> So, the idea there is
induction is crucial, and
the inductive bias is crucial.
We'll talk about all of this in,
in the course.
>> Kay.
>> But that's kind of a fundamental
notion behind supervised learning and
machine learning in general.
>> I agree with that.
>> Agreed?
>> Yeah.
>> Al lright, so we're on the same page.
So that's supervised learning.
Supervised learning, you can talk about
it in these high muckity muck ways, but
at the end of the day,
it's function approximation.
It's figuring out how to take
a bunch of training examples and
coming up with some function
that generalizes beyond
the data that you see.
>> So, why wouldn't you call
it function induction, then?
>> because someone said
supervised learning first.
Well, there is a-
>> No, no, no, no, no.
Sorry.
You said supervised learning is function
approximation and I want to say,
why don't you say supervised
learning is function induction.
>> As opposed to function approximation?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
It's a
>> Approximate function induction.
>> Or induction of approximate, of.
>> Approximate functions?
>> Approximate functions,
something like that, yeah.
>> You don't want to induce
an approximate function,
you want to induce the actual function.
>> Yeah, but sometimes you can't,
>> Yeah.
>> Because sometimes you think
it's quadratic, but it's not.
>> I have that as a plaque on my wall.
>> You do?
>> No.
>> Yeah I didn't think so.
Okay so that's supervised learning